most of the skills that you need to
succeed are not taught in school if you
have to get motivated every single day
then you are in the wrong business I
don't think if people take enough
responsibility for where they are in
life the motivation watch a top ten with
believe nation what's up please nation I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you I'm Evan Carmichael and
here are my top ten rules for success
volume 4 enjoy also if you want to know
myself and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 254
confident series where every day for the
next 254 days I will send you a morning
video for free to help you build your
confidence the link to join is in the
description below if you're doing work
that you loved you're more likely to
follow through you're more likely to do
it because it doesn't feel like work
because you love doing it
surround yourself with greatness if you
want to be more confident you need to
surround yourself with things that make
you feel confident
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one develop valuable skills most of the
skills that you need to succeed are not
taught in school that's because these
skills cannot be taught from a textbook
they need to be learned by doing
they involve other people so today I'm
gonna give you the three most important
skills that I developed that if you can
get out there and start learning will
transform your business and your life
skill number one is learn to add value
if you want to have success in business
or in any relationship you need to learn
the add value you need to learn how to
understand what the people that you're
working with what they want what their
goals are you want to be their chief
goal officer be everybody's chief goal
officer you need to understand not just
what you want but what do they want what
are they trying to accomplish how can
you bring value to them how can you help
them get through whatever problem is in
front of them right now and the more you
add value the more money you're gonna
make the more partnerships you're gonna
make the more people are gonna want to
work with you talk about you be around
you because you are bringing everybody
else up skill number two is hustle while
you wait this is so important for
success you will find this in every
single entrepreneur who has success you
hustle while you wait there's a lot of
waiting in business there's a lot of
waiting for someone to get back to you
there's a lot of waiting for someone to
sign a contract is a lot of waiting a
lot of waiting a lot of waiting you know
on Christmas Day you might be working
making videos you while other people are
waiting like you're waiting you're
waiting you're waiting you're waiting
you're waiting so what do you do while
you wait you hustle you go work on other
things you start building momentum
somewhere else if you spend your life
waiting on other people and you're not
doing anything in the mean time you will
fail here's a good example yesterday
Alex came over yesterday was supposed to
my mentoring day I trained Alex I work
with him I spend a couple hours with him
helping him grow trying to dance salsa
he couldn't make it in time because he
had to go to a walk-in clinic for a foot
issue great what would most people do
most people when something gets
cancelled what do you do do you go watch
Netflix do you go check out Facebook do
you go consume content you just take it
as a break that's what most people do
somebody cancels on you what do you do
you take a break I deserve a break I've
been working really hard and is ever
break
what did i do yesterday when Alex
canceled I went to work I started
getting a head on YouTube day or so
getting a head on my research I started
get a head what I had to do today that's
the key you send something now you're
waiting for a response what are you
doing while you waiting for response
you're hustling against ten other people
you're growing you're building momentum
you're planning for the future you're
doing your grinding you're getting out
there and so that's one of the most
important skills you can develop while
you are waiting for somebody to get back
to you while you're waiting for yes or
no or your partner to do something you
are hustling on something else you need
to learn the hustle while you wait and
skill number three is put your goals
ahead of your convenience guys this is
important your goals will not be
convenient for you you going off and
doing that thing that is different that
is outside the norm that most people
don't have success with you want to you
have the audacity to go say I want to be
successful here you're waiting for it to
be convenient for you it will not be
convenient you will have to do things
that you are uncomfortable with you will
have to grow in ways that you never
imagined you growing because you have to
get outside you have to go and chase
things that are not going to be
convenient for you and so I look at my
my tour coming up as an example probably
the most common comment that I get from
people who are learning about the tour
is when are you gonna come to my city
when you're gonna come to Florida what
are you gonna come to London when you're
gonna come to New York when you're gonna
come to my city I'm not I'm not coming
on this tour I'm not maybe I come next
year maybe I never come if you're
waiting for me to come to your city for
you to get the information you need
you're gonna lose and it's not just me
it's anybody else you're waiting for
Tony Robbins to come to your city you
waiting for somebody else that come to
your city don't stop it you're gonna
lose you have to go out and put your
goals out of your convenient you're
waiting for it to be convenient for you
you're waiting for it to come to you
it's not you have to go out and claim it
you have to go up make it happen
rule number two love the climb if you
have to get motivated every single day
then you are in the wrong business if
you are in your business because you
thought it was a hot opportunity or a
path to make some quick money get out
immediately shut it all down you can't
sustain motivation for that business
don't start a podcast if you don't love
talking or interviewing with people
don't become an influencer if you have
nothing to say don't start a daycare if
you don't love kids it's not worth it
and you're never going to win the work
itself needs to be motivating most days
you're gonna wake up and have a pile of
crap to deal with and if you don't love
gin with that crap you will get crushed
by someone who does enjoy dealing with
that crap the trick is you need to do
work that you love that other people
think is crap
that's the secret so looking at my
channel as an example this YouTube
channel has grown from 7,000 followers
subscribers to 1.7 million in a matter
of four and a half years and I love the
climb and I love passing people on the
way and I love the competitive spirit of
it and I know there's still so much room
to grow but sometimes I secretly hope
that the whole thing goes away so just
so that I could start and do it again
I'm just short of sabotaging myself
although I have taken some some risks
recently if you look at my channel last
month or two months ago I did some major
changes that did not work I bet
everything and going down the premier
direction just because just because I
wanted to have some variety just because
I wanted to take a big bet and it tagged
hard and it was my wor subscriber gain
in in years and I love it I love it I
mean I don't love that I lost but I love
I love pushing I love trying to get
better I love climbing I love trying to
find a new way to be able to go and
build and get better and I think you
have to love the climb I'm just short of
massively sabotaging myself and closing
down the whole thing just to start over
but I love the climb that much it's why
I love Instagram I'm going hardcore
Instagram right now halfway through the
year I had six or seven or eight
something like that thousand followers
and now now I'm at almost 80,000
followers but still posting six times a
day and by going live five times a week
and by making three to eight to 20
stories a day and doing IG TV and all
that
I love the climb I love I love when
people look at my YouTube channel and
say you have 1.7 million subscribers but
you only have six thousand followers in
Instagram like what are you doing you're
a joke
love it I love it I love it I love
looking at everybody who's ahead and and
having the ladder to climb up again I
love it all the people who I pass on You
Tube are all crushing me on Instagram
and I love it so much and it's not doing
it only to beat somebody else it's just
a competition I like the competition
I like frequent things out I like I like
the hustle and the grind to try to win I
don't like being number one I like
chasing down number one number three
take responsibility I don't think people
take enough responsibility for where
they are in life I think it's too easy
to blame other people it's too easy to
blame your government or blame your
family for not having the right
connections or blame your bank for not
giving you the money or you know blame
your circumstances it's too easy the
thing that you need to do the taking
responsibility is painful it's painful
it's way easier to say well I'm not
successful because of this person or
this person or this person it's not
because of you now of course not it's
because of your president that's why
you're not successful and it's not until
you actually look yourself in the mirror
and realize that there is no cavalry
coming to save the day for you
you know there's no fairy godmother
coming down to grant your every wish
it's on you and you are responsible for
where you are right now you you may not
be responsible for you know where you're
born but once you become an adult you
know you're a salsa for your life you
can only blame your parents and blame
your upbringing for so long where if you
want to make a dramatic change in your
life you have the power to do it and
there's tons of people who've done it
and there's tons of people who who
started with way less look good most
successful famous entrepreneurs people
that you look up to people who think now
are living the big life look at where
they started look at where they came
from chances are they had way less in
terms of money in terms of Education in
terms of resource and some connections
than what you already have right now the
difference is their mindset the
difference is that they took
responsibility for where they're at the
difference is they said if I'm gonna get
to where I need to go nobody's gonna
hand it to me
I need to do this myself and so if you
look yourself in the mirror and you're
saying why am I not successful and
you're coming back with excuses then
that's what you need to change
I recognize that as soon as you
understand that this is on you to change
your life it's on you to build your
business and nobody's coming to save you
and that you can do it once you accept
responsibility things start to change
rule number four develop will power will
power comes from setting goals and
keeping those commitments to yourself
when you set a goal and you complete it
you build more willpower you are
teaching yourself you're training
yourself that you are the kind of person
who sets goals and sees them through and
finishes them which gives you greater
willpower to go off and take on bigger
and bigger and bigger goals but when you
set a goal for yourself and you don't
follow through you don't complete it
you're teaching yourself you're wiring
your brain that you're the kind of
person who doesn't have a lot of
willpower you're training yourself that
you are the kind of person who does not
follow through who quits when it gets
tough so that's why it's so important
that you are very careful about the
goals that you set for yourself because
once you set a goal you have to finish
it you have to follow through because
that will change your perspective of
yourself if you finish it and you do it
will power grows if you don't finish it
and you quit willpower drops so here's a
quick example for my life I was driving
a Boston I drove there with with my wife
of my film team we decided we go for the
weekend and it was a long drive to get
the boss how long was Nina eight hours
ten hours
how long was a drive something like in
the eight hours it was late we got in
super late we got into what 2:00 in the
morning 1:00 in the morning
something crazy after an entire day of
me driving I'm not sleeping in the car
I'm driving doing the whole leg myself
driving the team I arrived super late
everybody's going to bed and I had set a
goal for myself that I was gonna run for
30 minutes a day I was gonna run for 30
minutes every day that was my goal that
was my commitment to myself now
we get there it's late everybody's going
to sleep it would have been very easy
for me to go to sleep it would have been
very easy for me to let myself off the
hook and say it's okay it's late you
know I'll do
tomorrow I'll do double tomorrow it's
late it's no problem it's very easy for
the people around me to say don't worry
about it happen like it's late that you
can do it tomorrow everybody will let
you off the hook when everybody else
will let you off the hook and you want
to let yourself off the hook that that
moment exactly precisely is where you
develop or lose your willpower because
when it's easy when your calendar is
perfect when there's no interruptions
when you have all the time in the world
to do something then you do it it's easy
it doesn't build your willpower you
don't feel great about yourself you if
you win a race against three-year-olds
you don't feel great you're not cheering
that victory but when it's hard when you
don't think you can do it when
everybody's saying don't worry about it
when you feel like you're at your your
wit's end when there's every excuse and
every reason in the world why you
shouldn't do it and then you still do it
that's when you build willpower it's
when it's difficult and you do it that
you build willpower and so I did my run
at 1:00 in the morning on whatever time
it was and it was a brutal run it was
not my best run I did not burn a lot of
calories it was not my peak I'm tired
I'm gassed I'm doing my run and even
though I didn't get a fantastic physical
benefit from it and even though the next
day I woke up and was more tired
compared to the people on my team
because I slept less I'm giving myself
Pat's on the back I'm giving myself
high-fives like crazy I've just built my
willpower I've just built my credibility
with myself I've just built my respect
and confidence internally because I did
the thing that I promised that I would
do when it got hard
that's difference that's how you build
willpower rule number five don't care
what others think I think it's really
important for entrepreneurs to
understand were your threshold is of how
much crap you could take from other
people how much negativity how much
feedback and criticism that you could
take without it impacting your psyche or
your self-worth I think in general as an
entrepreneur you need to be prepared to
get a lot of crap a lot of negativity a
lot of stuff thrown at you and yes it's
easy to say don't care what other people
think but
understanding what your tolerance level
is and where you kind of fit on that
spectrum can really help you design the
rules so that they're in your favor so
as an example this is a guy on my team
who doesn't handle criticism as well you
know I'm a lot more comfortable in the
uncomfortable where he can bounce around
a lot more of who be on top of the world
like this is great and then a negative
feedback comes in and it really impacts
him hardly and then the positive one
comes in he jumps back up and so for
someone like him you can't design as
much risk as much a negativity or
potential negativity so you got to take
us a safe path up where for me I'm more
comfortable in the uncomfortable I know
that eventually something's gonna work
out and I know that at the beginning of
any project is gonna be rough that it
made a hut workout then we're gonna get
some criticism and so I'm more willing
to jump all in and play in that field
even though it's painful at the moment
because I know the faster I get to that
pain the fast we're gonna come out the
other side I want that feedback and
criticism negativity as soon as possible
so that I can make it better better for
you better for me better for everybody
and so understanding what your tolerance
level is of emotional stability how much
you can take from your friends and your
family and your customers and your
audience and the people watching you
before you break and then be able to
play just below that limit because you
can't just play super safe because
that's not going to make you happy as an
entrepreneur but knowing your limit
isn't playing just below it so that it's
uncomfortable it's painful but you're
still gonna be able to get through it I
think it's really important that
self-awareness I think it's really
important as an entrepreneur rule number
six master your craft you put too much
faith in the tools it's not about the
tools it's not about the tools that
you're using it's not about the suit
that you're wearing it's not about the
car that you're driving it's about you
at the end of the day it comes down to
you I was asked to do a roundup of
different entrepreneurs of what your
favorite tool was to help you build your
business and they asked me and they
asked 30 other people what is the tool
that you love most that helps drive your
business forward and I was the only one
who didn't want to give a tool everybody
listed their tools and I was at the end
of the day I was posted at the very
the tools don't matter stop blaming the
tools and tools are important don't get
me wrong I love using tools I think
YouTube is a great tool I think cameras
are a great tool I use tools every
single day in my business to help spread
my message and help my company grow but
it's not the reliance on the tools this
is where I think a lot of people fall
down I had an entrepreneur friend of
mine come to me says what tools do you
use for your calendar how do you keep
track of your to dues because she had
tried using a notebook and using
Evernote and using OneNote and using all
sorts of different tools using her phone
everything and nothing was working you
know what the problem is not the tools
the problem is you write the tools can
help you go faster but if you don't have
the mindset if you don't have the
ambition if you don't have the drive if
you're not putting in the work then the
tools will never save you and I think
people have an over reliance on the
tools and that's my biggest problem with
it the tools can help you do that last
20% but it's 80% you it's 80% the hustle
and the hard work to get really good at
the thing and the tool can help you go
further I see tools as like pouring
gasoline on a fire
you need to have a spark you need to
have a fire to get something going and
then the tool the gasoline can help it
explode but if you just pour gasoline on
wood nothing's gonna happen I think the
same thing about suits and cars I think
a lot of people think you wear suit now
you're going to be successful suit
doesn't mean anything clothing is an
expression of self not a place where you
get your self-worth somebody with no
suit on could go in and close a sale
because they are who they are they are
confident they can close that sale where
somebody who's only deriving confidence
from their suit will never win and so
yes tools are important but stop relying
on the tools get so darn good at the
thing that you're doing that you cannot
be ignored and then use the tools to
help you take it to the next level rule
number seven take your shot when I was
20 years old I missed my shot because I
was scared and I vowed never to do it
again I was in Paris I was on vacation I
was in University and I'm sitting here
with my map outside your notre-dame
Cathedral in Paris and a girl comes up
and asked me for directions but she was
a French girl
and it didn't twig until later that why
would a French grill be asking me for
directions in English didn't really make
sense right and then I thought you know
what I should ask her out if just see
what she's doing tonight should take her
to you know a strop for coffee or dinner
or something see what she's up to but it
was afraid I was afraid to do it I was
afraid to do it and I let her walk away
because really it was I was afraid of
rejection and as she's walking away the
note Radames on a river and I'm on one
side of the river as she crosses over to
the side of the river and I was so upset
at myself I was so upset that I didn't
take my shot I was so upset that I
didn't try at least try and when I did
was end up taking a picture and as I
took the picture she actually walked
behind one of the market stalls and I
didn't actually get her picture it's
fine so I had this beautiful picture of
this French you know Riverside and what
I did when I got home I was still upset
about it so I blew the picture up and I
put it on my wall I was actually trying
to find the picture to show you guys but
I couldn't find anywhere in my files I
blew it up there when I put in my wall
so I'm in University I blow it up and
put on my wall everybody who walks in
asked me what the picture and it just
looks like a nice beautiful French scene
but I didn't tell anybody what they've
really represented to me why I was
really so important and I looked at that
picture every day because the next time
that I had to take my shot I wanted to
go out and do it I didn't want to be
afraid I wanted to conquer my fear and
say yes and this served me really well a
year or so later when I had to make the
really tough decision do I take this job
that I always wanted I had these
high-paying job opportunities and
$100,000 started salad with the
companies that I really wanted to go out
or continue with my startup that was
failing that was making $300 a month the
logical practical safe easy thing to do
would have been to take the job it's
what I thought I always want it's what
my friends want it's what you're
supposed to do come
out of university I didn't want to live
with the regret of not knowing what
happened with my business and looking at
that picture daily reminded me to take
my shot the next time it comes around
and so I gave myself a year to say I'm
gonna push off those jobs they'll still
be there in a year even if it's not
those jobs at some other job I'm gonna
give this a shot I can deal with the
failure I could deal with the rejection
I can deal with that not working out
even though that's a really kind of
short-term intense pain what I can't
deal with is the regret of not knowing
because that's not some short-term
minimal pain that's forever if I chose
not to focus on my business and I took
that job I would forever look back on
that moment and think what if what if I
just tried a little bit harder what if I
gave it a little bit more yeah you know
when I wasn't working I wasn't getting
results but what if I gave it a little
bit more I did not want to live with
that regret and I'm sure you've had
moments in your life too when you didn't
take the shot when you had an
opportunity right in front of you and
you didn't go for it like Eminem says if
you had one shot one opportunity to
seize everything you ever wanted would
you take it and that picture on the wall
help me take my shot and I hope
sincerely that the next time you get
your chance at something that you don't
shrink down that you don't say no out of
fear that you don't say no because you
find some practical reason why you can't
do it that you take your shot and if
you've had those moments that you regret
where you wanted to take your shot and
you didn't give yourself a visual
reminder like I did in my room to say
this is not happening again next time
I'm gonna take my shot I hope you take
yours rule number eight don't quit so I
love the storm Colonel Sanders is one of
my favorite stories and examples to give
up an older entrepreneur this guy didn't
really start franchising his business
KFC until he was in his 60s and didn't
really become an icon or someone super
well-known until he was in his 70s how
many people quit too soon on their
business I can't tell you how many
people come up to me and say Evan I'm 25
years old
is it too late to get started like what
are you talking about and really just
comes down to just your belief system
here was a guy who was 62 years old when
he was franchising KFC where a lot of
people would be saying I'm getting ready
to retire I'm getting ready to slow down
I'm getting ready to wind things up you
know just ease into the rest of my life
I knew this a guy who said no I'm gonna
I'm gonna crush it I'm just getting
started I want to build an empire right
and this really comes down to whether
you believe it can happen or it can
happen you're right if you believe at 62
years old that you're too old to get
started on something new then you're
right and you won't take action but if
you believe that age is just a number
and 62 means you've got lots of
experience and you're ready to go crush
some new project then you're right as
well and so you have to be really
careful to pay attention to the story
that you're telling yourself because a
lot of times we're holding ourselves
back with these excuses of we're too old
we're too young we've come from the
wrong country we don't have the right
education you know the right parents on
and on and on and as long as you believe
that reinforcing story that it's going
to continue to perpetuate now in terms
of don't quitting there's a lot of icing
don't quit don't quit don't quit don't
quit you should not quit when it's your
dream when this is something that you
really really really really want to do
then you can't quit on it but if it's
something that you've lost the passion
for you don't feel energized by it
anymore
it feels like work to show up then
that's when you quit and some people ask
me should I quit this thing or not well
is it still your dream are you still
passionate about are you still excited
about it because if you are then you
enjoy the process
and yes you want to get the results and
yes you want to win and yes you want to
make the money yes what I have that
impact but you still enjoy the process
I'd like making YouTube videos this is
fun for me it's enjoyable for me I'm
growing through it and even if I wasn't
on the path to hitting a million
subscribers I would still be doing it
because I love doing it and if I was on
the path that hit a million subscribers
and I stopped liking it then I would
leave I would sell it I would go do
something else because you cannot do
great things when you don't love what
you do and so as long as it's still your
passion as long as it's still your dream
you have to keep going or you're gonna
live the rest of your life from your
gret if you've lost that passion then
get out immediately and go do something
else that does bring you excitement joy
energy fulfilment rule number nine -
despite fear fear is normal it's part of
what makes you human you would not be
human or you'd have some crazy condition
if you never felt fear I think the
people who say don't be afraid aren't
giving you practical advice it's be
afraid feel the fear and then step into
it and do it anyway and the more you get
used to taking on those fearful projects
that you're scared of the stronger
you'll get the more resistance you'll
get the higher tolerance you'll get to
do bigger better bolder badder things I
think the trick that was spotting the
fear here's what I think happens to most
people there's some opportunity that
comes along there's some moment that
comes along with this with a client or
meeting somebody or an event something
comes along that you're afraid of you're
afraid of doing it
it's gonna stretch you beyond what
you've ever done before and then what
you do is you rationalize saying no I
don't have the money to go to that event
I'm too busy to go and do that thing
right now you find the reason why you
can't go and do it you rationalize it
but really deep down the reason is
you're just afraid and until you spot
the fear until you understand that it's
really just the fear then you're never
gonna solve the problem so step one is
understanding when there is fear step
two is then stepping into it and doing
it anyway and a lot of this stuff is
just so subconscious you know we as
human beings are kind of trained to
when we're afraid something's gonna go
wrong and to be safe and so it's trying
to catch that subconscious action and
proactively change it so the example for
me when I was starting my youtube
channel my agent would tell me you have
to go out and do videos in public I want
you to go it on the street I make your
video in public my natural reaction was
fear but I didn't catch it initially it
was the gear won't be as good in public
you know I can't control the light
settings I'm gonna be bouncing around
with the camera it's not gonna be a
great experience for the people watching
why would I do that
I'm rationalizing a reason why I don't
have to do it we're really I'm just
afraid right you could solve all those
problems and he told me stop being
afraid and just go and do it
he got through it and let me see my own
fear and so I did it and when I first
went out and filmed in public I took out
it was my phone or my camera I don't
remember and I'm walking on the street
and then the postman is there as so as
soon as I see the postman I quiet down
though I could put the camera away
just walking normally and then when the
postman leaves I'm back to filming and
that time I know it it's like I'm I'm
doing it because I'm afraid and I got
pissed okay next time I got a Speak Up
next time I got to do better and so I
went out and forced myself to go and do
it again and I was walking past and
there were these construction workers
and instantly again the the panic sets
in like people are watching the
construction workers like I know they
don't really even care about me what I'm
saying what's happening on the street
but I forced myself through it it was
awkward it wasn't great I think I had to
redo it again anyway but I I took the
step I got better at it I recognized the
fear and I jumped into it and now to the
point where I'll make videos walking
down the hall I make videos when I'm at
Disneyland
Disney World you know I'll make videos
in the streets of anywhere and there's
still a moment even now after how many
videos I've done there's still a moment
of who's watching I think it's natural
normal it's
as strong as it used to be and more
importantly it doesn't limit me from
doing the things that I want to do and
so spotting the fear and not
rationalizing it away and not just doing
what your subconscious always does that
keeps you down where you are is so
important being truthful that the reason
why you said no or you're not taking
this opportunity is just because you're
afraid and the answer to say no should
never be because I'm afraid you want to
reject your system so whenever that's
the answer because I'm afraid to do it
now you have to do it I only retain the
last one for a very special bonus clip
is serve others if you are not happy in
life it's because you're not serving
enough I believe that humans are good
99.999% of humans are good there's a
tiny little fraction of a percent of
people who enjoy giving harm and hurting
others because they have some chemical
imbalance but apart from that people are
good and we are connected to each other
your highest purpose in life will come
from helping others but the next
question becomes how how do I do it how
do I find my higher purpose how do I
know what I'm supposed to do how do I
get Direction I'm gonna give you the
three-step process that I call the
purpose planner that will give you the
clarity that you're looking for I break
it down into your who your why and your
how let's start with the who your who is
your one word most important core value
everybody has a core value if you're a
human being you have a core value that
you believe in more than anything else
and when you understand who you are when
you understand you're singing the most
important core value then you're less
likely to be swayed by other people
you're less likely to live somebody
else's version of your life because they
have clarity and you don't when you do
not have clarity you end up chasing
everybody else's clarity you end up
doing their version because they have
certainty and you have no idea what
you're doing it's like you're walking on
quicksand and you're constantly sinking
and you know this is something greater
for you your one word your most
important core value is the rock that
you stand on when the rest of the world
is crumbling around you so for me is
belief my one word is belief that's what
I stand on if you love believe you're
gonna be a huge friend of this channel
because I talk about it in some form in
every video every video should use
believe
if you hate believe you're probably gone
by now you hate my channel and that's
okay go go do your thing somewhere else
you need to figure out your who you need
to figure out what your one word most
important core value is that becomes the
lens through which you see your entire
world and attracts the goodness into
your life step number two is your why
why do you do what you do now I'm a big
believer that your purpose comes from
your pain that whatever your most
painful moment was in life whatever you
struggled with the most growing up in
life whatever moment in life you felt
the most worthless as a human being your
highest purpose your greatest joy and
satisfaction will come from helping
people who are currently feeling the way
that you felt who are currently facing
that situation that you were in that you
hated the thing that you would never
wish upon anybody else in the world lots
of people are going through that thing
and if you can step in and help those
people that's gonna be so filling up
your soul I can't even explain it to you
for me my one word is believed that's my
who my why is I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur I hated my life I was
struggling as making a 300 dollars a
month I felt worthless as a human I felt
like I was bringing no value to the
world and that was massively frustrating
I felt alone and I didn't know what to
do that's why I love helping
entrepreneurs I love believing in
entrepreneurs why entrepreneurs could be
anybody believe in anybody believe it's
at the core of Who I am it's my one word
most important core value but I could be
believe it in anybody and I do and I
love it but entrepreneurs hold that
special spot for me and the startup
entrepreneurs not the ones who are
already making tons of money I love them
too but I resonates so much more with
the startup entrepreneurs because I
remember what it's like eating at
McDonald's and only being able to afford
french fries instead of an entire meal
so your why your purpose comes from your
pain figure out what that most painful
moment was for you and it's hard cuz
entrepreneurs we like looking and being
optimistic and looking forward and being
positive but it's in that pain that your
answer actually is find out what that
most painful moment was your why your
highest purpose will come from helping
people who are currently facing that
right now and in Sept 3 is the how so
how are you gonna do it there's a lot of
ways you can help people who are in that
situation so for me you break it down
the who is my one word it's believed the
wise helping entrepreneurs purpose comes
from my pain now how do I
entrepreneurs how do I believe in
entrepreneurs is that there's a ton of
ways that I could be believing in
entrepreneurs so the example I use if is
if you are moving your office and you
need my help to rent a moving truck and
to help you carry your desks and all of
that stuff I love the end result of it I
love that now you have this great office
where you can build a business and have
it flourish and I'll probably say yes to
helping you do that so if you're a close
friend but I don't love the process of
moving I don't love the process of
packing up boxes I don't love the
process of setting up cables and wires
and putting together an office I don't
love that process I love the result
because I'm believing in entrepreneurs
but I don't with the process and so if
you write down you make a list of all
the things that you do the activities
that you have done that you've enjoyed
the result make a list of ten to fifteen
times you've helped somebody with that
same pain that you had growing up you've
helped them and you enjoyed the end
result and then circle the ones where
you enjoyed the process as well because
when you can enjoy the process and you
enjoy the end result it's a home run now
you've found your higher purpose now you
have clarity now you have a plan that's
the point of the purpose planner step
one you figure out your who your one
word most important core value step two
you figure out your why your purpose
comes in your pain the thing that you
never want anybody to ever have to
experience again because they're so
painful for you and then step three as a
how the process you need to love the
process if you go those three things you
are set for life a really special bonus
tip on how to strive for excellence that
I think you're going to enjoy but before
that I said with a three point landing
question it's time to move from just
watching another video to taking action
in your life for business and if you're
feeling bold leave your answers in the
comments below here we go question
number one how can you better serve
others today number two where do you
need to act even though you're afraid
and number three
whose opinion do you need to stop caring
about life isn't fair the family you're
born into the country you're born into
your religion your skin color your
gender there's a lot of very real things
that exist in this world a lot of very
real prejudices that hold people back
life isn't
and chances are you might not have the
capital or the education of the
resources or the parents of the family
of the connections or the right skin
color or the right gender any of these
things you might not have it all lined
up for you perfectly and so the next
step is then what do you respond to so
yes you're right and then what are you
gonna be like what most people do is
they just complain they complain the
life isn't fair they complain that they
don't have the right circumstances and
then they become a victim of those
circumstances or are you gonna take the
more difficult path the one of taking
personal responsibility personal
accountability and choosing excellence
and saying I'm gonna break free of this
mold
I'm gonna break free of the
circumstances that were placed above me
I'm gonna set my own path I'm gonna make
the world better for myself and the
people around me I'm gonna choose
excellence if you look at the people
that you love the people you look up to
the people that I profiled in this
channel whoever your heroes are your
role models the people who you aspire to
be chances are they came from nothing
chances are they had tons of odds
stacked against them and they chose
excellence and that's why they want look
at Michelle Obama her father was an
employee at a city water plant her
mother was a secretary and then once she
had kids was a stay-at-home mom so
Michelle Obama is the daughter of a city
water plant employee and secretary turn
stay-at-home mom and chances are again
whoever you look up to they have a
similar story it's very very very rare
and I've covered lots of these people I
may have covered more than anybody
online I've covered lots of successful
people it's very very very rare that the
son or daughter of a great person goes
on to do great things themselves it's
very rare that the kids of people who've
done amazing things go on to do amazing
things themselves
it's very rare it doesn't happen that
often and you might think that sounds
crazy these kids of super successful
people have everything
not for them have the money the
education the resources all the time in
the world everything handed them on a
silver platter it's so easy for them to
win and that's why they don't win
because you win through the struggle
because you win by overcoming the yan
because that's how you develop
excellence by going after the difficult
things the people who have an easy life
never win the people will have a hard
life and overcome and choose excellent
and drive daily and refuse to be a
victim with those circumstances those
are the people who ultimately win and so
that's you right now if you you feel
like the world is unfair first of all
you're right and second there's a bug
there's a bunch of things that are
stacked against you then I would highly
highly highly encourage you to surround
yourself with the stories of people who
have made it with the stories of people
who look like you who have the same
background as you or the same
circumstances as you who made it because
if they could make it then you can too
and most of the people that I've
profiled most of the people have done
videos on this channel look at their
stories chances are they came from a
worse upbringing than what you have
right now they had less than what you
have right now when they started and one
of my favorite stories is Oprah Winfrey
and she was so poor growing up you know
she grew up without parents she grew up
being abused by her family she grew up
with her grandmother who had no money
and put together dresses made of the
potato bags can you imagine going to
school in a potato bag that was sewn
into a dress like how the ridicule would
be from your classmates at school
wearing a potato bag as a dress to
school can you imagine that
and look what Oprah went on to do are
you gonna tell me that you have a worse
upbringing what Oprah head or any of
your heroes spend the time don't look at
how Michelle Obama or Oprah Winfrey or
any of these people make an extra
million dollars right now spend it time
to look at their backstory spend the
time to understand where they came from
and when they chose excellence and how I
had a massive difference and
trajectory of their life because if they
could do it you can too
you just have to decide that one life
isn't fair and that's okay and two I'm
gonna choose excellence I'm gonna stop
being a victim of my circumstances and I
decide to make things better for myself
for my community and for the people
around me
if you want to see my other top ten
rules video check out the link right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there the people who win work the
hardest because they love what they do
if you just focus on the money you're
never gonna get it this is what so many
entrepreneurs do and why so many
entrepreneurs fail